vulnerability is frightening you can't
expect other people to follow your lead
um and to engage in that unless you're
willing to do it yourself and so I'm
always trying to model that on this
podcast because there's a great strength
in that we think that it's weak or we're
afraid to show people who we really are
but weakness is keeping it to yourself I
it takes courage to share those things
and and every time that I have and I've
seen other people do it not only
does that set them on a trajectory
towards uh greater self-actualization
and healing it's empowering and it's
received welcomingly by those who are on
the receiving end of it